so welcome to um this workshop session
on developing embedded applications in
rust
my name is wolf and i
work for reddit
on the drug iot project
that project is about
creating a connectivity later layer for
iot devices that support
ingress of different events for http
mqtt co-app or for a lower on the
network
but it's also a
has a device side
which is a framework for writing a
microcontroller firmware and this is we
are doing in rust
unfortunately
we couldn't have this workshop in person
in brno because i was imagining we'd all
have these boards that were playing with
um
so i'll try to restructure it a bit so
that
you can follow it without
having the hardware
yourself
you might need to install the rest tool
chain and and things in order to compile
so you can if you go to the session page
on the shed dot com then you can find
some of the
links to the git repositories and stuff
there if you wanna follow
um
yeah so we're gonna
start a bit about why we're uh
actually doing rust for embedded
in the first place
um
because that's you know there's a lot of
uh existing things written in c
um and then also see what what would
actually rust uh
help you with
and then we're going to uh
sort of go through these rust
applications uh layer by layer uh
starting with uh
like directly accessing the hardware
then sort of seeing what abstractions
that you you can use in order to
make your software
you know better better and uh
also more efficient
and we'll end up with some application
that actually talks to
the cloud
and uh i'll try to do most of these uh
live but uh i might i have some
recordings in in in case there's a
demo monster is showing up
um
so yeah let's uh start uh first what do
i mean by embedded because some people
mean different things about embedded
than me
and
i know people think that maybe a
tiny device with the four gigabytes of
ram is a embedded device running linux
but uh
in this case it's uh
very tiny microcontrollers that only
have kilobytes of ram
they only have uh
kilobytes maybe a megabyte or two of
flash
for the program itself and then there's
no operating system around to help you
run the software um
and there's also no usually no memory
allocator although you can supply your
own of course but uh it's very bare
metal as a we call it
um
and what what is rust
well it's a programming language which
has kind of found its niche in
software where you need
full control over your memory and also
execution time
this is typically maybe operating
systems language runtimes or embedded
but it started out as a browse range in
project so
it focuses on performance of course then
and also being reliable it has a lot of
compile time mechanisms for catching a
lot of
programming mistakes that you simply
cannot catch in
other languages at compile time if
you're not using some static analyzer
for instance
um
and also trying to be still be
productive like not not
not very hard to use but in my personal
opinion it's
is might be a hard initial learning
curve to rest
but
i think once you
get familiar with the language you're
starting to see uh
productivity so
um
but uh what's wrong with c right we uh
we've been using that for a long time
uh
everybody writes
applications in c
uh there's a lot of real-time operating
systems and sdks from all the hardware
vendors
written in c
so it's a very hard
tough decision actually to sort of say
oh no we're going to write this in rust
instead
this new thing that we don't know if
people are using
but there are a lot of companies using
it and
many people have
rust
code in production so it's not that
new
but let's start with the problems with c
let's try and sort of see why
what can rust offer
so we'll take a simple c code example
here
like describing the issue of data races
um and this is a common source an
embedded uh especially
when you have these interrupts coming
from all the peripherals of your
hardware
and then
you don't really have a good way to
ensure that you're
not accidentally
writing and reading from the same data
from two different contexts so you might
have some application that reads a
counter in one
during the idle
run
loop and then you get an interrupt from
your peripheral and then that's modifies
the counter and then you don't really
know if you have a consistent value
so
you know this this example is all using
a single global variable and you know
that's
generally a bad practice of course but
that's often usually the way things are
done in embedded c because you want to
have a predictable footprint and know
what how much memory you're actually
consuming at the compile time
but it only gets more complicated once
you have started having multiple
interrupts at multiple priorities and so
on so
and
another problem with c is this tooling
there's not really a single build tool
or a dependency manager you have
projects using make someone using cmake
then you have something called west for
zephyr and python and the newt and
so
i end up using a different
uh
dependency and build tool depending on
what um
what project you're using
so
as we're
everyone who's been programming higher
level languages like you know java go or
javascript they know that you need some
some dependency manager in order to
manage your
dependencies
and uh
ensuring that
well it makes it easier to
get be productive really
um
so
can we do better
so by the way this this gnome that i
keep putting on my slides this is kind
of our uh let's say mascot
uh so you can sort of imagine
he's he's saying these things right
okay so
let's take a look at what the the same
example looks like in rust uh you have a
global counter
you have something reading it that's
something modifying it and
you this might be your first into the
first
thing rust syntax but it should not
hopefully should hopefully not be too
different from c
but
you have uh
a con global variable which you denote
using the static keyword and then you
say that it's mutable by using the mutt
keyword
and then
when then you can notice that whenever
you're accessing it you're actually
wrapping the
your code in a unsafe block
and this is because if you didn't do
that then the compiler would not
compile your program
it would see that
hey you're accessing a global mutable
variable uh from two this two different
functions we can't really know if this
is
this is not thread safe you know
because an integer is not thread safe
so that's why i have to use unsafe so
uh
so your program can work but
in this case it won't work more than see
the c version it's just that you're
sort of saying i can shoot myself in the
foot so
the the proper way to do this
would be to have maybe some uh
synchronization types uh and you can see
how pretty that is
having this
type name mutex
wrapping a cell wrapping a integer it's
not that pretty either but it's actually
safe and
and the compiler will allow it
um
but you probably want to do
something like atomics in this case
which
has a type signatures that
makes the compiler allow you to use it
without an unsafe block the same way as
the
the mutex that i just showing
so embedded rust
let's talk let's talk a bit about uh
how this is done so in rust you have
something called the standard library
uh
and with the standard library you have
the heap where you can do dynamic memory
allocation you have collections
all the usual collections people know
about
you have
basically a lot of
language framework for for doing stuff
which you already have in all the other
languages right but when you're running
on a microcontroller you can't really
use this because it would consume too
much memory and flash
so you have a mode called the no std
which means you are not able to access
the standard library um
there are replacements for the standard
collections that where you declare yours
you know
how many items you're going to put in
your vector before your
program runs
so that that's fine but also then you
can sort of waste space
but that that mode is really ideal for
writing firmware uh kernels or a
bootloader code where you want a minimal
footprint
and buffer micro controllers of course
which is the whole point of this
workshop really
and then in rust you have a single
dependency tool called the cargo
and the cargo is really great because
it can it allows you to
just specify the versions of your
dependencies and it will pull them from
the central repository called crates.io
[Music]
and
you can also point it to just your file
system or
github directly so it's very flexible in
this this way and
we'll we will see how how this works but
you have a manifest which describes your
software your firmware
um and then
you declare everything it needs in order
to build
and the this this tool can be used to
compile your software for just your pc
uh and cross-compile to any embedded
target architecture as well so
it's really nice not having to
jump between
modes
the rest
ecosystem
in the community is built around a
layered approach where you have you
start with a microcontroller on the
bottom
uh and you can sort of your software can
access the hardware directly if you want
to but
um for most microcontrollers there is a
peripheral access crate
and this
provides the
register definitions for how to access
the different devices on your
microcontroller like the spi bus i2c bus
or
cpu registers that you need to to access
um
and the user when you're using the
peripheral access crates that's usually
unsafe code because
it doesn't guarantee that only one can
access
the registers at the same
or sorry access
devices in the same in a in a safe way
let's say you can have
maybe there's some higher level
restrictions that you can't write to one
register while doing this other thing
and that's usually enforced at the layer
above which is called a hardware
extraction abstraction layer
implementation
and this is where you have uh maybe an
sbi type or
a sensor or whatever
that
works across multiple
variants of a microcontroller like for
stm32 they have like
probably several hundreds variants so
having to
sort of modify your code whenever you're
going to change it to work on one or the
other would be really painful
but the nice thing is that
it prevents you from doing stupid things
with your microcontroller
and then if you
want to write drivers uh for a
particular temperature sensor or
accelerometer or whatever
then you typically want it to work with
all these different spi buses that
exists in the world
so that's why there's a hardware
extraction layer trait
or api as it's typically known in other
languages where
which defines a common behavior of all
sbi peripherals
so when you're writing your driver
you're using those apis
as a base and then it will work on any
microcontroller and on the top is your
application
so enough talk let's uh
get to the uh
workshop or demo itself
um
the hardware
i'll be using is a development kit from
stm32
let's see if you can see it this is what
it looks like in the
real life
the reason i chose this one is basically
because it has
a wi-fi
chip on board
which we'll use but it also has
bluetooth
uh radio and uh
a lot of sensors like uh i think it even
has a gyroscope and the
accelerometer
um humidity sensor temperature sensor
and we'll use the temperature sensor and
then a few buttons so um
it kind of you can use it to play around
with
embedded stuff
um
yeah so and um
we're going to use it with our draw our
cloud instance eventually but uh
we'll start off with just a hello world
because that's uh
uh sort of you have to do that
so we'll um
look at that basic eras project
uh
you'll notice there is uh
two files there one is the cargo tumble
file and a cargo lock file so
the cargo towel file is the manifest or
our project
there's these
very commonly known
things like
metadata about your uh software the name
of your package its version
and the addition which points to a
specific addition of rust the rest
language
that this package will work with
then you have a list of dependencies
in our case
this is dependencies that
allow you to access the microcontroller
registers itself
the
rt stands for run time which is
basically a
very thin
shim that sets up some of the very
common registration that applies to all
of the cortex cortex-m
microcontrollers for running your
application
so you don't really want to do anything
different there usually
and then
there's a peripheral access crate for
our particular board
um
and you can see here i have some more
information because you can in rest you
can have compile time features
for libraries so that when you're
building your project
uh you can
skip features you don't want and enable
features you want
which allows
for instance a library to
to support things that work with the
standard library and
a subset of that that only works for
embedded for instance
and then there's
a few libraries for doing logging
this is commonly used because it's a
very efficient logging
implementation that
doesn't actually transfer the whole log
string across the debug probe
then there's uh
uh
a panic behavior if your program crashes
then it actually prints the uh
backtrace across the debug
debugger so that's
useful
um the cargo log file is basically a
sort of a
manifestation of your dependencies and
their dependencies so it keeps a full
track
of the whole um
list of dependencies that you need to
to build your application
this is useful if you want to
audit
your dependencies and track licenses and
stuff like that
before we look into the application
there's also um
another file we want to look at which
is a bit special for embedded
and basically it defines a few things
like uh
some flags to the compiler um
you don't really need to know what these
are doing but it it basically provides
some linker scripts
so that
it works correctly on
the cortex and platforms and then
the target
build architecture is specified here so
that the car the
cargo the the build tool will know which
uh microcontroller to compile your code
for
um
the build tool also has a way to run
your application so if you just do cargo
run you can run
an application on your pc uh for
embedded you want to actually run it on
your microcontroller so that's why you
have a tool called probe run
mentioned here
and specifying actually which
microcontroller is using so we can
actually run our embedded application
like
any other application
so let's run it
so this first flag environment variable
i'm setting here enables logging at
info level
the logging is enabled at compile time
because
doing it at runtime is you know
it comes with a cost of extra
uh code then dash dash release is just
to produce more compact code really
and then uh we run the replicate our
application and it
prints a little world
okay so that's
the first step
uh let's go back to
slides
so
um
i'm just mentioning that if you're
following if you're trying to re do
these steps uh
then
when you have the if you have the rest
installed using the rest up tool then
uh once you have that
that you don't need to do anything else
other than maybe installing this uh
tool to run it if you have uh
if you have this board yourself
so
um
let's do some more something more
exciting
let's blink an led by pressing a button
it's like super advanced stuff uh and um
on this board we have a
blue button that we can
press
um
and it will light an led
uh yeah where i'm having this
on the slide
and then
we'll see how we can
build an application from the ground up
doing that and then see
these different layers that i talked
about earlier
so we'll start at the
the the peripheral access crate so we'll
we'll see how an application looks like
for that
so
let's look at the money first first
in this case uh
and it's almost the same dependencies
like the hello world using a different
peripheral access credit that
the
our team is sort of contributing to
this allows you to select which
microcontroller you want to use at
compile time
which is
really nice because there's so many
variants of them
so there's a lot of difference there
our application though it's quite
different
so first
you'll see is
we have a
declaration at the top
which is the
marker that
this is a
an application that's not using the
standard library
so the compiler will not will sort of
fail if you're trying to use the
standard library
then you also have
some of the debug
debug logic being imported
and finally have this
uh peripheral access create imported so
these are just import declarations
your application starts in your main
entry point
which you will annotate with uh
this
macro as it's called and
it basically does it's sets up the uh
the
microcontroller interrupt vectors and
and uh
launches into your main application
so uh yeah to blink on led using the
peripheral access crate that's pretty uh
hard
first you need to enable the
the clock
on your
board
which you can do like this and you can
see we have to use unsafe code
we have to modify some registers enable
the
various gpio ports so it's
it's not it's not trivial
then
you need to
set up your
button so that it can actually
uh
intercept these signals when you're
pressing it
that's also not that very easy you have
you have to sort of say which which
button it is
you have some more unsafe code to modify
registers don't worry if you don't
understand this this code is that's not
really important it's just to show that
this is really uh
not a code that's hard to read
um finally we need to set up the led as
well
so uh
yeah it's uh just all of this you can
if you look at the reference manual for
your microcontroller that's when you see
which register you need to see it set
and which value
and then we have the rest api that helps
us ensuring which values we can actually
set so there's some
usefulness to the peripheral access
criteria in that
it prevents us from setting invalid
values to the registers
and that's good
and then our main loop is basically
click the pin of your button
and if it's pressed then
like the led and if not yeah
do not light the led
let's set it just 70 lights of code to
blink an led
and uh
we can try and run this and see if it
works in the
live okay so now it's running on my chip
and i will press the button
you can see the l there's a green led
there oh and with my finger where it's
blinking
okay
that's
uh using the peripheral access crate and
let's see where i was
there
oh
what we should take a look at now is how
would you do this at the
peripheral access crate no at a hardware
extraction abstraction layer um
and
that's a lot better
um let's take a look at the manifest
first
um
now instead of the meta pack we are now
importing the
hulk from embassy which is this project
that uh
where using in drug
um
and this is uh
a run time but also uh
on hal for
accessing the hardware
and
we'll see how much simpler this is it's
uh
this is the entire application
so we're importing these types from the
hull that
uh specify what an input pin and output
pin and what these things are
and our main application is basically
just
saying
to the hardware extract abstraction
layer initialize my microcontroller
and then you can use these higher level
types
to say that my led is an output
using this particular
port
and starts at high
and then the button is an input
at this particular port
these port definitions are part of the
user manual of the board so this will
vary depending on which port your board
you're using
and then there's the main loop which is
just looping checking if the button is
pressed if it is then a name that
light up the lead if not
turn it off
so
as you can see this is a lot simpler
and more understandable application even
if you don't really know rust that well
you can sort of get a feel for what it's
doing i think
um
oh
let's try and run it
if it actually works
it does
oops yeah all right
i hit the cable
okay so um
that's
um
that's the hull but there's one problem
with it and that's that
the application is continuously
busy looping
checking for the state of the button and
that's not very power efficient
so we want to do
more low power stuff
and
the way to do that
typically is using interrupts
so let's look take a look at an example
where you're actually doing that first
and then
see a variable from there
these dependencies are essentially the
same so i won't really
with that
let's look at the application
now you can see
this is a lot more complex
you have to
you can initialize the hal and your
initialize your
buttons as before
handle led
but now you have to
think about bit differently because you
need these types to be accessible by
your interrupt handler
which is declared down here
and then the interrupt handler needs to
check the state of the button and then
enable uh disable the led
so
and the main application needs to
when it's created the ldn button it
needs to enable interrupt for the button
so that you get a trigger when it's
pushed
and then it also needs to set these
global variables that reference the
button and the led
and yeah this if you saw this earlier in
the slides which is it's pretty ugly in
my opinion where you have to declare all
these types and
you know have these complex type
signatures for everything
and
your main loop is basically just
sleeping
all the time and then the interrupt
handler is the one that's actually uh
lighting up the buttons and so on
uh so that's that's that um
but we need to test it and see if it
runs
it runs i think so
still blinking
so uh
you know that's
so now we're using low power uh that's
nice but
uh
it's not really nice for uh
the power uh and i know it's not really
nice code to maintain
so uh
what we need to do is
i'm sorry
we what we can do with this is to use
some frameworks of course that deal with
this ugliness for us
there is a project called arctic which
is uh
let's say a task shade scheduler for
rest
there's a project called the tok which
is an rtos real-time operating system
and also called hubris
these have
some advantages in that they
they sold a lot of the level of access
for you but also one of the great things
about rust in my opinion is that
all of these libraries that i can use on
the shared repository
you can sort of mix and match exactly
what you need for your application very
easily you don't have this in the c
world so that's why i think you end up
with all of these real-time operating
systems and projects that sort of solve
everything whereas in rest you can sort
of you know pick and play pick exactly
what you want and compose your
application that way
the thing will be using here is
something a project called embassy
which is a project uh
my my team and and i have been
contributing
to
to bring it up the speed but it was
initially made by someone who actually
uh run it on their
production
firmwares
and
embassy is basically this hull that
we've seen that abstracts the hardware
but it's also a run time
um
and it's actually an async runtime so
and
async is really a
unique language feature of rust
especially in terms of embedded
because
people who are familiar with you know
futures and promises and async in
highline higher level languages often
things they are nice because
you avoid this callback hell or
or these event complex event loops
and uh rust has the same thing but in
rust
they are actually
uh let's say zero cost they don't
need uh
an allocator to work
and uh embassy is actually a runtime
that allows you to run these
asynchronous tasks
continuously
uh so
just
quickly explaining what what what how
this works is that you have
an executor which runs these
tasks and you have a set of tasks in
your firmware
and then what the executor does is just
check with each task is
do can you make progress
if it can then it will try to try to do
so when it
needs to yield execution because it
can't do anything else
then it returns uh something called
pending
and then when it does that then the
executor tries checks with the next task
and so on
and this is
this is uh
very similar to any like scheduling
system but um it
you can do so with these tasks which are
declare asynchronously which means they
can
be written in this async syntax
so what happens when you have have
interrupts for instance in in for
instance is that
your task
might say that i'm going to wait for
this interrupt now
and then it's
when the executor pulls it
it says oh i don't have anything else to
do i just need waiting for this
interrupt
and when the interrupt occurs then the
interrupt handler will sort of set some
state in the peripheral saying that
ah you should uh you should
you're you're done with your operation
now and then it
tells the executor that and then
that again
checks with the task do you have can you
make progress and then
yes the task can make progress so
uh that's very simplified how this works
it's a very complex topic as well but i
just wanted to oops i wanted to
cover it
quickly
so
let's take a look at how this
looks in
rest
um
now in addition to this hardware
hardware hardware abstraction layer
we have a runtime
dependency
and we'll see how our application is
structured again now
and
now it's a lot simpler again
you have
still a main function this time it's a
different type signature it has an async
keyword
it has uh some arguments
for instance
the peripherals
uh of your microcontroller which you can
access this way so you don't need to
call this init function manually
and it has a spawner which allows you to
create spawn new tasks
and you set up your you create your
peripherals the same way
so before
and the main loop is almost identical to
the the first busy looping one except
for one minor detail
which is that
before checking the button state is
actually waiting for any event on the
button to occur
and in this case that means an interrupt
and it's using the
await keyword for that what this does is
it's saying that this task that is
running here is just saying to the
executor
when it's calling await it's saying uh
i'm waiting for a button interrupt
i can't do anything else right now and
then the executor will sort of put the
whole system to sleep
until it receives this event and then
wake the tasks again
and then it will continue and check if
the
button has changed state or not
uh so this
yeah so this
is clearly
very readable
compared to this interrupt version
and
let's see if it runs
okay
it does
and the great thing with this is that
this is just as low power as the
interrupt version it just has a minor
overhead of switching the tasks but
you can write
you know low power
interrupt driven code in a very uh
similar way as you would
write blocking code
so let's go to the next step which is um
actors
um
i need to lead up a bit uh so the actors
is
something used in web frameworks and uh
you know people are familiar with
which is a
framework for composing person by actors
are really async tasks
that
receive some
messages in their inbox they check this
and then they
act on that state and
that's what rogue device is about
so let's look at how this looks for
that
so with actors
you're still using the embassy runtime
but now you're
creating actors called leds
and buttons
and then you're sort of mounting them
into the runtime
and
why i'm showing is this this is that
if you look at
the previous example the async version
then then you have to sort of say that
this is
i'm checking the button for being in a
low state and then i'm
setting the led to be
high and
then if instead the system knew what
that meant like
if this button that does something then
this led should do something then that
can be uh modeled as actors where
you have a button actor that emits this
event to an led actor and then the led
actor knows what to do
so that's what we're doing here we're
not defining any behavior
in our application
just wiring things together
uh it's a bit it's a bit more complex
side type signatures because
actors need to be global you know
because
they they they keep some state and need
to be able to
uh
run
uh
the processing loop
for for forever so this
you have this if you're it's the same as
spawning a task in embassy and instead
this task is a
is a task plus a uh in a message queue
basically
um
okay
that's
actors i can
talk more about that later if you have
time
so enough with the blinking
let's try and
and see if we can do something uh more
complex
uh so in this case uh our real
application is uh
is uh using this board sending some data
recording some temperature data using
the temperature sensor and then sending
that to the to the cloud
so first
let's take a look at the
temperature application
um
look at the manifest we now have a
dependency in addition here that's
depending on drove device
and so this is the drug iot project
for the firmware
and then
our main application is basically um
a bit more more of the same really but
it instead of just a button on the led
it's an i2c bus
where you declare
which pins it's supposed to use on the
board uh it's actually using bma which
is
a really beauty of async rust is that
you can do dma like it was just regular
code
because the
when a dma operation is completed then
you sort of you can program can't
continue so it's
a good fit for that
we have the
some pins related to the sensor we're
using
the temperature sensor
and then
you have these uh
actors in the system so i'm using actors
one actor for the i2c bus
this is allow using an actor for it
allows you to share it between different
parts of your application because it
will ensure that only one
uh
one request is being handled by the the
peripheral at the time so actors are
great for
sharing state
and then there's the sensor itself we're
using a temperature driver that's part
of drug device
and our application which is our own
actor which we'll take a look at
so the sensor will use the
i2c actor to read the data
and
then there's a button actor which when
pressed will invoke
the application which will then ask the
sensor for the data
um
so i'll skip the uh looking at the actor
itself because we don't really have time
for it
or we can do
we'll try and run it
okay so i'm just pressing the button
here
and it's
seems to be quite hot in my room
uh
yeah
that's it
uh
but you'll notice that the the program i
wrote didn't have much
you know logic
application logic
so let's go to the um
next
sorry
so now we want to report the temperature
to uh to the cloud
this will be our last example so once
i'm done with this we can do some q a
um
i'll go to the terminal again and we'll
have a quick look at the application
so
it's
building on this sensor application that
i was just showing in addition now we're
adding some configuration of uh the
cloud endpoint which is you know first
we need to call next to the wi-fi
network
and the cloud endpoint we're going to
use
the username and password
for uh
for accessing and then there's some
board support crates that help us
use the correct peripherals of our board
so yeah basically you uh instantiate the
board
you set up wi-fi
oops
and then
you join the wi-fi network
and you basically setting up the actors
of the system again
you know the only additional actor now
is the wi-fi actor
and the wi-fi actor is
passed on to the application which will
use it to send data so now your
application can work with any
net any actor
that implements these
functionality of the
wi-fi
and that's it the button is is about the
same
and
in this case i'll um
i'll run a video of the demo because i
want to be sure that everything was
working so now
i'm using the
rogue iot endpoint
this is the console of drug iot
where you can view messages entering the
the system
and we run your application then
it's joining the network
on the board and then
we can press the button to send data
and then it appears in the in the cloud
so you can
if you want to
look more into the details of the the
application itself it's all available
online and
i'm open for questions
about it as well
so let's go to slides
so some final notes what have we seen
what have we learned
um
so
if you're uh if this peaked your
interest in uh rest embedded uh please
join the community there's uh
some
matrix.org chat channels that you can
join there's they're pretty active with
people
uh doing all sorts of interesting
projects
and uh
there's uh even like a weekly meeting
that you can uh join
uh some some uh
links to useful uh
resources for learning
embedded rust there's a book in the um
uh
rust embedded organization uh which
explains a lot of these uh things more
basically and in more detail than i've
done today
uh there's a few useful frameworks like
the arctic that i mentioned
and the embassy which i'm also working
on
and the drug iot project itself
which is like this cloud endpoint and as
well as the device
stuff
i'm